like I just think we're kind of at a
weird place in the conservative movement
we're calling like a fight between a
couple abuse like I just didn't see
abuse in that and I just I guess I have
a different point of view on this from
interviewing so many men that have been
victims of divorce really that have been
divorce rate and what I've noticed is
like a lot of women will put Clips out
of context to make a guy look bad so
when I see like Clips or texts get leaks
I'm just a bit more skeptical because
you know there's two sides to every
story and in this you know my question
is why were you sitting on a cliff from
like two years ago